el martes 2 de Agosto ya ha llegado a
Taiwán pero con una incógnita sin
despejar la eventual visita de la
presidenta de la cámara de
representantes de Estados Unidos Nancy
pelosi a su territorio la funcionaria
estadounidense empezó su gira asiática
en Singapur y según los principales
medios taiwaneses llegará la misma noche
del martes sería la política de más alto
Rango en visitar el territorio en 25
años y para china significaría una grave
afrentado si viene a Taiwán interferirá
gravemente en los asuntos internos de
China socavará seriamente la soberanía
de China y su integridad territorial
pisoteará Sinvergüenza del principio de
una sola china amenazará seriamente la
paz y la estabilidad en el estrecho de
Taiwán y dañará gravemente las
relaciones entre China y Estados Unidos
el gobierno chino ha llegado al punto de
avisar que su ejército no permanecerá de
brazos cruzados
teme que la visita de pelosi y refuerza
el reclamo de soberanía de Taiwán que es
independiente de facto desde 1945 pero
que china sostiene que forma parte de su
territorio nacional Estados Unidos había
logrado el equilibrio al declararse
neutral públicamente y reconocer el
gobierno chino como interlocutor una
política conocida como la política de
una sola China y según la Casa Blanca
eso se mantiene intacto
la presidenta de la cámara tiene el
derecho de visitar Taiwán y la
presidenta de la cámara ha visitado
Taiwán en el pasado Sin incidentes igual
que muchos miembros del Congreso incluso
este año el mundo ha visto del gobierno
de Estados Unidos ser muy claro Nada ha
cambiado en la política de una sola
China para Estados Unidos Beijing usa
como excusa la visita de pelosi para
aumentar su agresividad en el estrecho
de Taiwán la franja de mar que separa la
isla de China continental y por el que
pasan miles de barcos vitales para el
comercio mundial el estrecho ya conoció
el conflicto en los años 50 y tras
décadas de cálma tensa podría estar
cerca de conocerlo de nuevo
[Música]